la ministra principal de Escocia Nicola
storean hizo una locución el pasado
miércoles que nadie esperaba en ella
anunció la dimisión a su cargo y también
al liderazgo del colectivo
independentista Partido Nacional escocés
con lo que terminan sus ocho años de
gobierno la Popular líder ha sido
criticada por promover el proyecto de
ley reforma de reconocimiento de género
una norma que facilitaría que las
personas cambien legalmente su género y
lo puedan hacer desde los 16 años sino
desde los 18 como es ahora la crítica
aumentó porque la mujer trans fue
ubicada en una prisión femenina a pesar
de que cuando era hombre violó a dos
mujeres Londres vetó la norma además de
presionar en contra del segundo
referéndum de independencia de Escocia
que promovía precisamente de la ministra
stock John para hablar del tema nos
acompaña de nuestro estudio en Bogotá
profesor asociado de geopolítica de la
Universidad de la sabana profesor buenas
Buenos días y bienvenido aquí a France
24 Hola buenos días bueno a pesar de que
la renuncia se da en todo este contexto
la ministra storeon negó que las razones
estuvieran ligadas tanto a la ley de
cambio de género como al referendo usted
cuál cree que realmente sea la razón Y
si dio este debate de la política de
cambio de género en un momento político
adecuado bueno como siempre en esta
situación hay diferentes razones por
tomar una decisión así por parte de la
ministra
seguramente después de nueve años en el
poder en Escocia y en el poder en su
propio partido también existe cierto
agotamiento personal de su parte pero
también obviamente de los votantes
después del covid
Escocia fue uno de los países del Mundo
con las medidas más estrictas encontrar
el covid
las cifras socioeconómicas también son
favorables
y obviamente
el objetivo principal de su propio
partido es realmente liderazgo sea hacia
la independencia de Reino Unido Y eso es
algo que ya durante nueve años no ha
podido lograr y ahora obviamente temas
como esta ley de cambio de la identidad
de género
no le ayudan tampoco a niclass en su
imagen popular y precisamente menciona
que la independencia de Escocia del
Reino Unido es una de las banderas del
partido de Nicolas sin embargo también
era una de sus banderas personales y de
hecho ella llegó al poder en 2014
después de un referendo en el que el 55%
de los escoceses votaron a favor de
quedarse con el Reino Unido y el 45%
votó a favor de irse del Reino Unido
ahora no estará al frente del país Estas
ideas independentistas mueren con ella o
los escoceses realmente seguirán
apostándole a retirarse de Londres yo
creo que en términos generales los
escoceses van a seguir con este deseo de
independizarse de Londres de Reino Unido
sin embargo en la situación actual y con
el liderazgo tiene que hacer hasta ahora
seguramente en este momento los
escocesos no tienen el deseo inmediato
pensando por ejemplo en la situación
económica en la situación de los
servicios públicos de que son
relativamente peores que en el resto del
Reino Unido yo creo que los escoceses en
el futuro inmediato no tiene el deseo de
otra vez intentar a independizarse y
obviamente su propio partido ahora
también se tiene que renovar
usted ha mencionado varios temas
pandemia Independencia y también la ley
para reformar el cambio de género en
medio de todo esto Cuáles diría usted
que son los aciertos y los desaciertos
que tuvo Nicolás en sus ocho años de
gobierno yo creo que ya durante mucho
tiempo seguramente hasta la pandemia
fue una política y una líder muy popular
en Escocia
y a ganó varias elecciones
fue la política que básicamente
determinó la agenda política de Escocia
fue una voz muy fuerte en la campaña del
brexit y del referéndum hace unos años
también pero obviamente yo creo que
después de unos años ella empezó a
enfocarse más en políticas muy
progresistas por ejemplo esta ley hace
poco y
no poder lograr a un punto definitivo
con este tema de la independencia
realmente es el tema que acabó
el apoyo de los votantes de Escocia para
Nicolás entonces teniendo en cuenta que
la defensa de la independencia fue lo
que acabó como usted lo dice tanto
astorgen como su partido nacionalista
escocés qué va a pasar entonces se acaba
el partido ahora que no está Esto ni que
la independencia será el tema más
batallado el partido seguramente Ahora
tiene un gran desafío en renovarse
en los próximos meses y años hay dos
candidatos que pueden llevar a cabo este
este proyecto
hay otro partido
independentista del predecesor de
el examen que también puede obviamente
sea competencia para el
Nacional de Escocia y los partidos más
tradicionales como los laboristas Que
obviamente están en contra de la
independencia de Escocia ahora ganan más
favorrabilidad entre los votantes usted
menciona si en el nombre que yo sí los
voy a dar uno es el parlamentario
robertson y la otra es la ex secretaria
de finanzas Kate Force ambos del partido
nacionalista escocés cuál de ellos Usted
cree que podría ser el nuevo Primer
Ministro el ministro principal de
Escocia perdón y aquí una aclaración
afirmó Que no se retira del cargo hasta
que su reemplazo esté y ya su partido
comenzó a abrir posibilidades para
recibir candidaturas y de Forbes Nicolás
ha dicho que es una de las mujeres más
inteligentes que ha conocido en su
carrera política cuál de ellos dos es el
más opcionado y qué necesitarían para
lograr la unidad y la popularidad que
logró Nicolás Bueno antes que nada
no se está retirando ahora mismo Sí y
eso puede causar ciertos problemas
dentro de esta elección o Selección del
próximo líder del partido
en este momento
[Música]
Aunque
sí tiene el apoyo de
Yo veo que ambos robots tienen más apoyo
dentro del partido Simplemente porque él
parece como una persona que puede
pacificar el partido en este momento Y
eso sí quizás es algo que es más
importante Además él fue parlamentario
en Londres en el parlamento de Reino
Unido Entonces él tiene mucha
experiencia en el manejo de las
relaciones entre Escocia entre edimburgo
y Londres en un momento en el que sin
duda la necesitarán por las tensiones
que hay frente a la negación de la
reforma y también la negación de un
segundo intento de referendo
independentista ahora le quiero
preguntar brevemente
porno que fue el Antiguo mentor de
Nicolas torrillon y luego ellos se
dividieron y sabemos se convirtió en su
principal opositor cuéntenos muy
brevemente Por qué este distanciamiento
y que tantas probabilidades tiene salmón
de realmente llegar a ser el ministro
principal de Escocia
bueno como usted acaba de decir el
examen
promovió la carrera política de nickell
Station luego había una pelea personal y
política entre los dos había casos de
corrupción dentro del partido Nacional
de Escocia
el examen empezó el tomó la decisión de
empezó de empezar su propio partido
político de político que se llama Alba y
obviamente cada vez que que eso pasa
como la división de este movimiento
hacia la independencia hay mucha
animosidad entre esos dos personajes y
es muy interesante que estén ahora está
saliendo del escenario político mientras
el examen todavía